شكرًا لك
بالقرب من الخطوط الأمامية لباكمود ، النفوس المفقودة
تتجول في الشوارع ، أولئك الذين لا يستطيعون المغادرة
لن يغادروا أو يتخلوا عن الرعاية ،
لقد وضعت بعض الطعام على النار ، لقد قطعت
بعض الخشب ، تقول فيتلانا وقررت
الخروج للحصول على بعض الهواء
النقي الذي يدفع ديميترو  لا استمع إلى القصف ،
فهذه هي أرضي ، يقول إنني لن أترك
كل شيء على ما
يرام في القتال.
كانوا يحلقون فوق رؤوسهم الآن
، لقد
أعد الجنود خنادق داخل
المدينة مواقع دفاعية جديدة إذا
دفع الروس
أكياس الرمل إلى الأمام مع وجود الخشب في الأعلى ، كما يقول
فالنتين وثلاثة مواقع إطلاق نار
على الجانب الغربي الأكثر أمانًا
من المدينة ، حيث يوفر سوق مؤقت
أساسيات
مع  لا توجد كهرباء أو مياه جارية
يتم إجراء التجارة في العراء ،
يمكنني ممارسة
الأعمال التجارية ، لقد تم تدمير متجري ، كما يقول ديني ،
لذلك أنا أبيع في الشارع
ولكن هذا الطعام  فقط بالنسبة لأولئك الذين
يستطيعون تحمل تكاليفها ،
أنا أعيش كحيوان مزعج يقول إن
إيفون تعود إلى المنزل بعد جمع
الحطب ، فالبرد القارس قاتل حيث
تجمد الناس حتى الموت في
شقتهم ، كما يقول
في خدعة تطل على باهاموت ،
يلقب ضابط المدفعية هذا  يقول بيلاتي
إنهم يواجهون قوات العديد من المدانين
في الشركة العسكرية الخاصة
التي نقاتلها ضد الجنود الذين تم إحضارهم
إلى المذبحة ، ويقول إن هؤلاء
الرجال فاجنر ليس لديهم خيار أن يُحكم عليهم بالإعدام
، ثم يأتي الأمر بإطلاق النار على
بن ويتمان سي إن إن